people love hearing about
uh what you know brilliant folks like
yourself
uh could recommend in terms of books of
course you're an author of many books
so i'll in the introduction mention all
the books you've written
people should definitely read live wired
i've gotten a chance to read some of it
it's amazing
but is there three books technical
fiction
philosophical that had an impact on you
when you were younger or today and uh
books perhaps some of which you would uh
want to recommend that others read
uh you know as an undergraduate i
majored in british american literature
that was my
major because i love literature i grew
up with
literature my father had these extensive
bookshelves and so
i grew up in the mountains in new mexico
and so that was mostly why i spent my
time was reading books but
um you know i love uh
you know faulkner hemingway i love many
south american authors
gabriel garcia marquez and italia calvin
i would actually recommend invisible
cities i just i
loved that book by italo calvino sorry
it's a book of fiction um uh
anthony door wrote a book called all the
light we cannot see
which actually uh was inspired by
incognito by
exactly what we were talking about
earlier about how you can only see a
little bit of
the what we call visible light in the
electromagnetic radiation i
wrote about this in the incognito and
then he reviewed incognito for the
washington oh no
that's awesome and then he wrote this
book the book has nothing to do with
that but that's where the title comes
from
yeah all the light we cannot see is
about the rest of the spectrum but
um the that's a absolutely gorgeous book
uh
that's a book of fiction yeah it's a
book of fiction
what's it about it takes place during
world war ii uh about these two young
people one of whom is blind
and um yeah anything else so
any so you mentioned hemingway i mean uh
old man the sea
what uh what's your favorite uh um
snozzy kilimanjaro uh oh wow
short stories i love um as far as not as
far as non-fiction goes i
grew up uh with cosmos both watching the
pbs series
that reading the book and that
influenced me a huge amount in terms of
what i do
i as from the time i was a kid i felt
like i want to be carl sagan like i just
that's what i loved
and in the end i just you know i studied
space physics for a while as an
undergrad
but then i in my last semester
discovered neuroscience
last semester and i just thought well
i'm hooked on that so
the carl sagan of the brain is the
aspiration
yeah i mean uh you're doing you're doing
um
an incredible job of it
you